you look good okay thank you look at
this well so food podcast with Felipe
Esparza and Rodrigo towards ego toy was
so full chilling we have guests today
reg showed up right away by now you know
punctual he'll 40 minutes later on or
coming at the last minute by parking
that's why like a rock shoe ality man
well that's the other kids that just
crawled out of here while we're talking
it's worse in my resources Grandma's Boy
it's worth it wait what do you mean he
crawled out like we were doing the
interview and then he goes to loop in
them so uh it's like okay I have to go
the night when he crawls out he really
crawled out and I thought was a good
activist can he crawl out into his car
yeah no he's over yeah he looked like he
was hating it though he got up at on
10:00 in the morning he showed up here
but he showed up and he can't he may be
here at noon and crawled out crowd out
around 45 minutes later treated in and
crawled out if you creep and crawl out
you might as well call in and say I'm
not going to but that was like
responsible vocally for the night before
and took over and called yeah with only
two hours late yeah shut up man
I like Jodie Amell night to book him at
the wild coyotes for fifty bucks
Phillippe I will talk a lot I'm over at
Lankershim fighting ninjas you got a
good and no offense to you Rodrigo and I
got a very good Joey Diaz impression
yeah even better though there's like
different Joey Diaz oh they'll win then
I know I said this guy's [ __ ]
Brown yeah three arms on one shoulder
like a [ __ ] angel they get to ice up
one right there yeah Philippe backwards
but the times paper alright I'm gonna go
back to my little [ __ ] shell top the
engineers Omar that's another food that
we ate to watch him on I to follow what
he does I should follow what you did to
and what you guys did okay well do you
follow up no life one now we're our Last
Comic Standing like the last day I saw
the attention of Natasha with a bag of
clothes and Filipe and they're selling
all the clothes
I told you to sell clothes oh they were
selling rrrrah wardrobe for now daddies
that's a [ __ ] give me a suit I do them
some tight suits right there do one last
comment yeah one I yes you judge I was
responsible for that to work I was like
I mean I was a part of you winning you
were part of the Felipe family I was
part of the Felipe fan club yeah
originating so G Felipe fan club hey
don't remind them I was weird because I
thought like when I did the audition you
know you were a judge great judge by the
way no you were real you didn't kiss ass
you know the man if your person thought
he saw what my manager tell me to say
yeah manly it was good I think another
good judge they were have a judge or be
honest to really tell it could be how
horrible they were will be on Thank You
Paula or Jamie Masada alright Jamie
Masada Ronaldo was like that it was good
all right
I said no to you but I thought you said
yes on the audition because I feel about
you you said I love Felipe at the
audition you know when there were no
people but then on camera said she said
no that what if they cut this and redo
it or work with us and let me
manipulated in some way speak to that
why do you know why did you say no to
our beloved host I don't remember
anything about that job but I will say
that sometimes what would happen was the
only thing I came in there thinking was
that I wanted to make sure I felt good
about everything I said so maybe you if
you said something that I thought was
too happy at that moment I might have
said no just because that was the only
basis I was judging things on like I
just was trying to be true to myself
I remember what those comedians that
were that were not pushed who didn't
know Natasha Natasha was they were upset
they want to happen but you don't know
who she was I knew what the three people
were okay I know you business either
you're performing the wrong places yeah
if you're in the mixer know who's who's
who I'm good I found my Slumdog
Millionaire on that show that's a little
boy that I had history with everybody
you know to say it I dream everybody
except and II know some guy told me he
was like big Fanny you Geraldo big fan
of Kindler Nancy
I don't know who you are oh oh that's
what you people know that the producer
still called me Nancy Nancy yeah man
because he I know greg Giraldo because I
opened for him when he won the day right
headlining and gene pompa would be 3
yeah he's good huh you and I know you
could I think I threw up in your room I
said out a Montreal Comedy Festival in
that room maybe that's why I always have
a weird vibe I felt like a mr. Joe be
there with me it was just a red oh there
was a lady from the San Francisco that
when the poster punchline
Molly Marley and it was in my room yeah
it was with the ural connected to my
room and Jay Larson
I didn't all together and we had like
this oh you guys were new things real
versus ok we were new faces together you
do things together smell money they
better 5 they put the new faces in like
that every single comedian at the entire
festival stays in the Hyatt except the
new faces they stay in this [ __ ]
residence in like 15 minutes away is so
bad and then they have a little family
there's a puke channel where Felipe can
come in did I get mad oh you're creating
something again no you were cool
actually no no no no you were cooking I
was about to like whoa and you brought
me a bucket I got a nice black guy was
original ice bucket challenge I told her
Judas you brought me an ice bucket and I
was after that to everybody I'm sorry
and I left I remember anything that I've
said or did in my whole entire life
right you don't have any memories before
the age of 15 right we also got Moshe
right what's up what's better
Oh a notable battles also a
schoolteacher below cool all the
substitutes here for a year where we're
at al borde Unified School District in
Riverside California and how much comedy
time did you get from that year well now
let's start out right there that's like
when I started doing comedy right there
I got a little audience and stuff but it
was kind of like got out of hand
my kids started laughing and like
getting all crazy in the room because
they knew you from the podcast no hell
no this way before that and I the
teacher will come up what's going on
over there oh nice
the teacher was Joey Diaz nod what's
going on in here right [ __ ] all
you guys are gonna come I'm gonna sit on
one of you guys right Philippe I think
am I wrong that do we have you on your
first podcast appearance the chance yes
the champion the Beast
what is beauty in the beauty of bees was
Felicia Michael than Jodi applaud I was
just your memory you know every single
thing that has ever happened to either
of you weren't even there manager does
your audio pick up a little bit right
here okay good good speakers at the pad
good headphones oh yeah so that was your
second podcast and the champ I just use
Rex and I don't know I feel responsible
for what's up full that was a badass
podcast yeah really good you guys said
you guys had good like it was good
chemistry and good questions in a it's a
story role per foot also Felipe you're
like a the dream podcast get I mean I
know now I'm your guest but you're like
a dream podcast guess because you just
go you press record and then go Felipe
tell a couple stories and then like an
hour and 20 minutes later like am cut
good night everybody is so easy and also
to with that podcast you guys are
usually doing like black dudes right and
he was the first one that was like nah
whoa did you break the color barrier
how'd you guys hook up with that like
how'd you hook up with the Neal Brennan
start the chance
I mean Neal called me one day I was like
do you want to do a podcast we were
trying to figure out an angle and we
thought at that time we thought you know
podcasting was so white like was so such
a white world and we thought who better
to break the color barrier than to also
white comedians we thought if anybody
else no one will do it but the way the
whites need
we're like Dances with Wolves you know
what I mean but we thought that you both
like have a fascination with black cops
we do we both and Doug Pound was he in
were you there yeah the Doug pound here
is ugh Tom so each of us in our own
weird wet ridiculous foolish way were
like enamored of a black culture as
weird and fetishes that is so we thought
well we know this is inherently
problematic and yet we're going to do it
anyway and by the time the champ stopped
being made I felt like it didn't need to
be around anymore I was pretty cool
though because I guess don't need to
last forever that's true too but what I
mean is like our mission
not that we were like I love podcasts
I just thought like by the time we
stopped doing it people like podcasting
had become more diverse and didn't need
a couple of white boys to like be doing
that that so I thought it was kind of a
cool arc but your podcast influence um
more people to do podcast I think I know
for sure I was in the podcast and I said
stories about my life that I never
shared before like community legally
alright and now I was doing in my new
special I am it always a hold on that
yes you're not gonna die soon your Park
I never told anyone
and people reference your podcast to
talk about me an interview oh I heard
somewhere that you said no bring her in
a champ yeah follow the way it is I'll
never forget your story about the
looking at the TV and going oh that's
stand up so you go to like a second-hand
store and buy a sports coat shoulder
pads and then rolls roll the sleeves up
like oh I guess is what stand-up comedy
looks like he's all he's like
referencing the Reagan presidency is
just like way faster are you always
funny yeah he's so shy though but funny
like you knew you want to be a comedian
I do want to be a comedian when I when I
saw it when I saw it on I heard it in a
record what was the first rank it was
the rush my brother Russell whom I sleep
with uh Bill Cosby Oh Bill Cosby the
episode that I sketched with him and
brother arguing about him being adopted
that's what you have those General
Hospital blankets uh-huh uh-huh that's
an album that built on yeah what do you
think about Bill Cosby Jesus well I
don't know man let's talk about it man I
think well what do you think welcome you
guys never talk about everything no not
too much right we never really touched
on it right oh man we know you're not
like all Kearney venti yeah how about
what hey hey hey as he was a jerk I was
like a victory can you really hey hey
hey hey
yeah yeah yeah he's a while back in
there yes hey so though victory Hey
actually he said who turned her back or
anywhere brave I swear he did that
that's a weird idea and he gave with a
cane everybody it's done rose to good
funny it was like Keyser söze style yeah
I still come because even if you think
it hey hey go cos you're here hey hey
here comes that poison is too late yeah
maybe I think he got off on this one
right this was a criminal trial he's
going to go on another one but it's
either 60 women that are telling the
truth and it sucks or 60 Liars or
whatever it is or 40 and 29 who is
saying it where the people didn't
understand two of the jurors apparently
were so dumb they don't understand
concept of a reasonable doubt they
didn't know what that meant that's why
he did that's a prosecutors job to
explain that to them right I mean I
don't know if that's true one of the
problems with the trial is that the man
was being accused by Liars that are
trying to bring down a powerful brother
you know one of the problems with the
trial was that he wasn't on trial for
the 60 he was on trial for kill yeah for
one or two yeah and so you have to leave
out of your mind
the the 60 when I so every back to that
particular count that case and I don't
know what somebody knows maybe the girl
was little off or her story tune that up
or and she had gotten a settlement
before that so it's like that's hush
money right now you're coming back with
this thing yeah but I'm a touch money
because he did it so now right in the
statute of limitations didn't run out on
it so now she has the case but it's also
a lot like that law it's not like that's
legal it's like your honor
after I raped her I gave her hush money
so I cannot be accused of this crime I
think euros to let the allegation go
yeah we're you know did you guys ever
see that clip of Cosby saying that he
puts a little um something why yes right
60s all right Larry no not the stand-up
clip the Larry King right that interview
dress you put they said I can't do a
cosmic person so I'll do this Joey did
it they said don't you put that drop a
drop of a jump of Spanish Fly it'll fit
on the tip of a needle put it in
drink hello America that's pretty said
hello my heart clip from an interview
and every King is just like hey I'm
gonna do I mean it's kind of upsetting
that he didn't get in trouble
I mean he's ruined right no matter what
he is also like an old-ass man they
should have got him when you know him
the [ __ ] was really crackin he right
and then his wife's come into a defense
you know calling out all the people I
got so exactly come to your defense you
would buy raped 60 women 60 women you
Bobby our cute little 510 yeah like so
in Italy are they are are they all
represented by a well-read no I don't
know what would you have opinions on
Gloria Allred well I just think I mean
she just goes where the money is at you
know she ain't gonna sue do they don't
have any cheese it doesn't have anything
it but I mean have to talk Cosby's a
target I mean there's something there
why didn't they build a case with the 60
or something to try to make it more
about your limitation has a rolling
system
oh yeah the rollin 60s they stay put a
kibosh on that yeah so that now that's
how it started her comedy career as a
member of the rollin 60s what is the
rolling fifties
okay that's good right positive
deniability doesn't want to let you know
that she knows what it's like a [ __ ]
okay yeah and I watch rolling species
from OSI baller that's right a mistake
yay
yeah men were you guys building games no
that's so racist did some kind of kid
back 10 yeah oh man I'm scary a rapper
out there no I yeah guys a question were
you both in gangs or are you illegal
immigrants which one oh do you have nice
nobody
either event I were you were a crew live
in the gang he was doing I was just in
later I was jumped in when I was 19 bit
of 13 years old
muscles it hurts a little more when
you're not sure you know yeah man but I
was I was like gum you know like you
know like I was eight and I was out I
was only there I will do a free drugs a
good time a good time I forgot to do bad
stuff like shooting somebody I would
love you back and you would slink out to
here with the homegirls 8e has everybody
left if you leave would be like hey hey
none of those Tyler will jump other
members and you know I was joined into
the jump identify some pool card to
Harry and then you say what's up man
Batman you wanna get your PIN now it had
no choices I just punch the little guy
next to me real hard
let him calm down I punched his face
open then I got jumped by everybody
would stopping me on my head like I was
in the game I was I was going to look I
was a little white boy game called PA g
the pure adrenaline gangsters that's
what they called well yes it was and as
I say in my book it was a name though so
so weak it should have been called th AG
the pure hardcore adrenaline gangsters
or sack well there was a I got I had so
many initiation rituals to get into that
pathetic like wannabe it's like a little
white boy game and we all thought we
were like tough and I had to swallow a
goldfish put a cigarette out of my arm
elbows right exactly right rule what's
that drive-by sleepover you have Barnard
know we would do drive-bys but our moms
would be driving porno together gang
yeah that kind of thing very clear day
since you've been in a gang so I'm
curious about this because I know
someone who's in who's like a 50 year
old in a game in a motorcycle department
but what's to like you shouldn't be like
over 30 and be in a gang right
hell no man years old with the funniest
thing I've ever heard was Corey Holcomb
one said mom bugs in LA is 40 years old
is still gang bangin
that's a good impression - that is
[ __ ] hilarious and they're still 50
ok yeah I think before my shoulder like
50 years old and they're they're still
gang banging Wow like if it goes down
we'll be done by even the littles baby
is gang banging that's how you're gonna
have a baby bottle
that's so sad though to be a like a
grown grandfather and still think that
gangs are important to still be like on
my block looking oh man you're a senior
you're in the AARP that's your block
your block is what you should walk to
the end of get winded in combat it's a
mentality yeah I know
he should be shooting up medicine though
shooting a Bible that's a good bit like
old gang game baby should not influence
the photo shoot of insulin like a
soldier just is pulling of the block to
stay alive everybody don't let me blow
down fusion section would you mean a
good premise would you grew up on
Natasha and also I didn't mean to imply
you're in a gang although I were like
speaking of like about like the 6ms what
are they criminals themistocles's the
ganglia like I said it is like he used
to be in the in the rollin sixties now
he's in the late sixties what's up fool
we had a yard sale right cool where we
moved resided and I we moved to it we
got our junk from into the house and we
we let our stands come in and buy it
wait you guys had like a fire sale and
yeah and buy your stuff that's crazy
dude yeah we put it on a podcast people
showed up and there was a woman a woman
who bought that desk she was a nice mom
whatever oh yeah I saw it too 10 bucks
and I saw having emerged for 5 bucks to
them and I took photos but this woman
who bought the desk she was a nice lady
man they looked at her arm she had the
big old gangster tattoo on her hand and
my crazy life she had a three dot what's
that called a plaka
a black guy yeah - yeah it looked like
this I'm from PA g-man
don't get it twisted I know all about
pockets but my Paco it was just an
ice-cream cone wait so she she was like
a nice lady in the gang and against it
that's when I don't want to ask you an
old lady she like 38 6 - the look nice
veteran status now yeah or like just a
square now but it still it was my right
to show the white lady right just you
headed on Oh like what I play all right
yeah yeah man tonight get that [ __ ]
removed still a hand tattoo must be hard
to remove though it's like do what this
the three little dots what is it for
forget Aloka I crazy like Mike Lee
that's one two three me vida loca yeah
interesting
yeah well G go mean tattoos nah not even
one
no nothing Moshe no no tattoos hell no
what about you that's it man big you do
it you have had this yeah a little bad
three right here but it was a mistake
man it was those people next to me
getting real tattoos so you had a holy
give me something first three God and I
went home I ran with no I held up my
hand my baby mamas mean by here then I
could then I'm Gabriel Iglesias he paid
for it to get removed because Moshe
jealous because he started dating her
here Charlotte so fluffy in the Sun see
I got a big old bad for that to get rid
of why cuz he just thought it was bad he
thought it was bad but you didn't want
to tell me what it is you're talking
about I wanna get this [ __ ] removes it
will get a tattoo to us does it hurt as
much to get it removed well yeah I wish
I was once with a girl who her whole
back was covered in the grave of her
dead father
I was just a 200 if you ever [ __ ] her
doggystyle excuse me Natasha forgive me
but I have [ __ ] girls doggystyle
before you and you would be looking at
her father's grave
kind of broke up a real eulogy here yeah
same birthday
I'm trying to add to your family and I'm
looking at somebody that took away from
it are you trying to get her pregnant
lush no I'm just doing a bit so Tasha or
whatever average whose and I look to
pursue sparkling a lot with his [ __ ]
Ganga here what's worse is that right
when I was about to come I saw two eyes
pop up on the grave what are you doing
with my daughter he has risen
come on me dog right oh come on me Doug
that's the only good thing he has to say
from the afterlife hey don't come on me
you two had the jacuzzi show yeah coming
with talks I love that show otherwise
where will you be a guest hell yeah
another great idea done for you Natasha
luckily I'm a bio jacuzzi to write it
off as a show I did do that the best
ideas running through the business what
a good idea right oh yeah oh [ __ ] it by
a minor Carter called a monocot opanka
he'd already came up with a bus another
good idea dude Oh NES
and he has the bingo bottle you have
thought about the win amenity so you cut
off this whole section of our house and
write it office of put your business
Natasha and I we started something
called the cocaine podcast or about a
kilo of cocaine that's right Jordan [ __ ]
that would be a good way for you to
break your sobriety coke just the
cocaine podcast oh you're all sober
right now man I've been sober for a long
time hello okay 22 years oh wow nothing
no weed no no no no you're doing it when
I was like I was just a kid you know I
was like being a little Phe boy and he's
not crawling out of podcast I went to
rehab when I was like you know 13 14
years old oh they're so bad of it yeah
man I either shoot up McDonald and now
it's insulins I went yes I was a
juvenile delinquent more than anything
else I just look like this now look like
a little dork now but if you see me one
out of 13 you would have run screaming
and what kind roset are you [ __ ] with
i mean yet you know acid weed meth Oh
[ __ ] could have been in a movie kids
yeah exactly that's exactly as well sure
I know my face Casper oh yeah I have a
team of you I have eight that
oh I'm sorry in the chest yesterday yeah
politically as kids man
yes yeah kids that was me 100% watching
that movie felt like watching a group of
my friends yeah I don't judge they're
hardcore dude I thought drugs were so
lame when I was young
is that true I thought that like beer
was like for fraternity guys I thought
drugs were for losers but I was still
cool like I feel like I was very lucky
to be cool what I heard she felt too
late oh man beers for losers that be
smoked pot bro give me my [ __ ] bread
I was in are 19 you know that when I
started to enjoy the 20 late I still a
man would be missing not in this [ __ ]
hahaha I'm beer you don't seem like a
drug pot but I mean I didn't try to toss
18 anyways I was kind of afraid but I
was always rolling joints for dudes that
were older than me when I was 14 to the
18 how come because they were in a band
at all a dude world is haunted I [ __ ]
break it up a little and they would you
would give them cornrows and stuff like
that I'm not about national bombers and
she did nice little doobies you know
that's hard to learn how to roll that's
interesting and it was a punk bad right
yeah blue do glucose oh that they're
famous right yes yeah or sometimes we
were like their little like you'd hook
up their equipment and he was like a bad
bad boy I ended up working at the record
store and then I'll just hanging out
when they were practicing this went in
there one day and then it's one day oh
you want a job you already hanging out
here anyway we're in [ __ ]
Riverside California now you want a job
rolling our joint
yeah and that was it dude that's how I
learn how to roll wait so is that like a
thing you have to learn how to do yeah I
want to do it properly you know I don't
want to brag but the rule of the best
blood yeah oh you're really good at it
yeah and then obviously you've got that
blue glow scoffs kill the global devudu
glow intern and NBC me professional
Snoop Dogg hire someone
yeah back I heard during the up in smoke
tour he had paid a brother of just roll
joints out that'd be a badass job that's
so funny I know a snoop once and he had
just like a cigarette case just like
fulla blunts ready to go just ready to
go yeah that's all smokes non-stop it's
so funny to me too because he doesn't
smoke cigarettes I don't think right no
he thought it was hilarious because he
smokes like 50 blood today it's like dog
you smoke cigarette nestlings 50 tobacco
leave the day he's turning into a
blender
right now yay yay it starts to stop its
its effect it does it's got to I've
already taught in myself like there's no
way Snoop really gets hired this is how
I know pot is bad it's an addictive
thing is because now when I smoke it I'm
like I didn't smoke enough
I need coconut I didn't think she'd far
enough did I smoke enough I need to
smoke more like I never used to think
that when I would smoke pot and I think
it just wears off
I feel when you start taking like that
you gotta stop smoking pot and please
you shouldn't smoke - smoke you know
social to feel paranoid again I'm going
to add the paranoia ballet like I smoke
a joint and walk into a library real
fast yeah so asking questions oh go to
the NSA on your own head so then you can
feel like you're stoned again the reason
I'm parents get real high I walk into
the mystic constant that's one of the
passport and realize when you walk it I
realize you don't like people I realized
my Spanish is not good enough to have a
conversation with a professional Mexican
man you mean he's a Mexican man that's a
professional or he is a Mexican man for
a living yeah like I don't like it is my
gardener on a professional Mexican yes
in my spare time I'm a black dude yes
like gardeners you know pool cleaners
electrician you can talk to them oh yeah
home people I got that back oh I got a
Chinese the highway I'm going to show up
you know that place is like making a
consonant
oh man I'm lost no copy they're like
conjugating verbs hell yeah even big
word I said I'm a FEMINIST lemundo up
the recipe question like so they're
asking me that question I told your
comedy premise in Spanish no no no
premise is a premises premies ah that is
annoying to look it up what do you do on
Telemundo was it that what's a to
Gigante
no idea they'd show that you were worse
than that where we showed yesterday bro
they paid us 700 bucks in cash really
we did a black Benito there's some oh
that's the one where all the comedians
hey yeah that's funny
that's the one that was a lot of that
Milo's dealer not public it for me you
don't know the tragedy shows they know
they know craft service and no residuals
my grandmother is cooking backstage I'm
not lying to you
your grandma got the job there's an old
lady there with a big old pot making
whatever she's making what is she making
goulash very hot of me
hey it's better than Doritos yeah they
recorded midnight days we got that 8
left early recording dude and were
dragged by the Burbank Airport they
record at midnight to the he does like 7
episodes in one night yeah but is that
the more they bring all the like it's
not spanish-speaking comedians like
Hannibal did it or something like yeah
he did it but here like here did they
Michael was a translator
oh enjoy it you could don't put you guys
on yeah I got an offer to do it once but
he sure don't worry I'll be funny yeah
guy the guy who Jay me Kim who is a big
fan of the show is something he like he
mentions him uh-huh he's old like a
Jalen he does like Jay Leno monologue
but just sub like home with a class he's
funny though man yeah he's four armies
and flattened Ito L shoulder memory so
nauseous
he got fired from Mexico that's why he's
in America now oh so it's Telemundo is
for Mexican American is Mexican American
television it doesn't broadcast a mostly
Mexican or Spanish peak Eilish speak
yeah it broadcast to Mexico it's mostly
uh I think it says Mexico or here too in
the state over here but uh plus a veto
him he's like it was like the BEP yeah
Plata nito's me a little little a little
banana the other class I know is a
regular cause my dick actually a little
banana that's okay laughter that's all
but is yellow though oh my god
ah but he's banana he's funny
or he got fired from his job in Mexico
that's why he's here he did the real
[ __ ] when I get hard for of a stand-up
comedy show or he did a joke they're
very offensive for everybody I was a
school church or of a school right
something happened a bunch of kids I was
a kid's got Birds regular buildings and
then he called he crazy he said I bother
they got burned I would like the Chicano
Kentucky Kentucky Fried children oh I'm
graphic art show at the time we in his
defend is their friend I said there were
arms and spices at the side when it when
he said this joke nobody even note
wasn't talking about the kids Bernie or
- I made a joke hmm so the defense you
come up with after you get in trouble
yeah oh he said what were they talking
about that like oh god they weren't even
given it any air player they weren't
even talking about all that he's like I
had to call them Kentucky Fried children
so your mom's would open and he gets
away with his real sexual innuendos that
no one else does
yeah he's very funny she's like there's
no there was a bronze Jane getting a
finger up his nose but another
basketball player and I'm Bethany to say
look it so this fellow your mom but in
Spanish it's funny man Chris said it's
okay I love you keep buying tied to your
right is it sponsored by tide grass
Colgate coke the loyal brand through
their Latino loyal brand oh yeah a coke
tide zest interesting zest like the most
like quintessential American water
bubble oh so more than anything you want
really Mexican home where I grew up
there's death there's a totally cleaners
tied and there's alcohol mate but I use
all those four and aha well then maybe
your mexic Ajax think about it
look at your wrists look down at your
palm on your hand and see other three
dots is there I'll eat one extra Quechua
missile so you started stand-up in LA or
Florida or New York Florida the only
have three choices
laura de ok so we are goes it I'm from
Illinois not Chicago and from Rockford
and then I moved to New York and then I
moved to LA and I started stand-up now
Florida okay okay you read and obese de
you're through our junior Oakland in
Oakland with luenell we would live now
Ramez a little bit before me actually my
favorite airport really yes
sure will we had we had on a podcast she
thought we were being recorded and we
got there she had a makeup on and Tel
Aviv lights
oh she had like she came with away she's
all done uh-huh
sorry about we're just recording okay I
don't know you have this stupid thing no
what is it it's a live stream right now
he'll Johnny fire here mm-hmm
yeah I starting 10 Francisco great
medical place lights on yeah I started
at out of a here natural fudge cafe with
the with the right host Manfredi Soto
Jamie Kennedy scintilla bean al Berman I
know all those give away did you start
before 2002 oh yeah Oh longer than us I
start like at 96 oh really
gambler had a baby at a baby at the time
so that will quit and then come back to
me and but that was sports code time
sports clothes time yep we are father
all right I'll tell you the first time I
walked into the natural fudge I met all
those great comics even Alonzo Bodden
was there and the the host Johnny
Roberts he said hey we're filming a show
next week come on down kid I love you
and after the oh [ __ ] I'm a bill
television Pacey I really have cable
Italy no local accent Billy me [ __ ] so I
thought [ __ ] yeah man we're gonna tape -
it's on oh it was a local TV cable
access yeah genital read you have that
sad del hell no no I'm not
that's what was you know what goes on
fountain Avenue that's the Dookie cafe
wait and that was a comedy club it was
like a cool oh no the
castrated the punk music and stand up
and stand up but mostly music so they
will have the comedian go up like Alonzo
Bodden and then like a band will show up
after him and then what please putting
down their equipment another comedian
shows up once the benefit is setting up
they play a five-minute set so you can
do in comedy for like 21 years 21 years
okay but working as a to meet at the
working comedian since 2010 what do you
say what do you think of like the PC
nature of everything like don't you
think things are getting more PC like do
you care about that since you've been
doing comedy for so long well I watch
people at Platon Ito and I'm I don't
care man no I don't my jaws are not that
hardcore but I've had people take the
microphone away from me what do you mean
get my sense right for what job because
I say my brother came out of prison
worse this time
can I would say my brother cover the
prisoner Nazi Mexican Nazi sometimes
real racist against blacks another time
he came out of better teeth but this
time we came out worse he came on a fool
he came on a border good Christian so I
feel I said that it got really low in
the room then it's battle anyway that's
enough for mr. Felipe
audience member you start later that
paid me the Booker knows it what is it
you say you offended our consular gmail
currency whatever our city attended a
slave City attended where were you
performing as some private club and some
golf court I got it got it but that is a
funny joke their pay was 200 bucks man
those corporate gigs men are the work
though I will tell you more than two
that was the bad joke but I had tags you
know she let me finish my son okay yeah
my mother loved blowing up abortion
clinics now he's crazy man that would
have won him back like this Felipe
character yes that was one you know I
would one well I never had a mic taken
out of my hand another
was that um when that black life matters
came out somebody had a meme and I
reposted it and said that um you know
it's cool you know black like metal but
went out when a Mexican guy took a car
we don't give a [ __ ] we just say well he
was a gangster issue he should die and
then everybody think why that offended
anybody too late and then everybody that
I've read called Mexican Latino
saturates who Reich are tools that
offended hmm I don't understand why
would you get offended if you do
cartoons but hasn't well I don't like to
me going after other comedian when they
did offended well I don't think
cartoonists are comedian or they
consider themselves yes everybody
considers himself a humorous now I tell
you this cartoonist I got offended but
his character and his cartoon is a
Mexican but he's a roach what do you
mean he's a cockroach yeah yeah I'm not
racist no I don't be racist
I think it's racist if it would didn't
come from him you know but his since
he's Mexican figures okay what this mean
something you came up with I'm not a
pilot example it took me a year to fit
of that joke out and so you did people
like just attack and feel it sucks when
people attack you online they attack me
men you know what you got to do turn
your mentions off then you'll never know
if they're title turn them off a little
fella I don't know if people talk [ __ ]
I'm like I'm blissfully ignorant I'm
just like posting into the wind another
word I got a Fed it was a little spotty
though I reposted it is this a bunch of
ladies hit me up you know various faster
neck down you're gonna lose a fan right
now like that I was a little baby with a
huge cheeky water out of the faucet like
crying and the me was when white babies
eat hot cheetos
I don't get what's a one lady out there
that didn't like it did that the baby
with being abused and waterboard odd you
know actually I know that lady and it's
actually it wasn't a lady its chester
Cheetah he didn't want you talking [ __ ]
about his product
oh man people get offended will you bro
I've been I've been like you know I've
gotten to my kid taken away from me and
I've been wandering club get the wacko
right well the black joke I remember in
a San Jose I did the black joke and it
was just like the Jesus joke and I -
ladies we don't know we don't like old
do you don't even do the joke anymore
but how's it go
Oh like I said it Jenny walk of water no
no Jesus black cause you - water -
kool-aid but it's also the part that I
added he's all so you know he's walking
up to the you know go get persecuted get
on the cross and it's like a little kids
are you gonna be out today Jesus is uh
hanging out and like you ladies like got
really nice you can't be doing that
mostly appendixes that's not just was
black he'll turn the water to cool eight
ya know she said on the other part
though that she was all I'm a Christian
woman and that's unacceptable I think
what man I said I was like damn I hate
it when you see somebody sitting there
laughing at every joke you make and then
you get to the part that they care about
like hey I take offense to that I'm a
Chris yeah my whole thing is homily so
like you know little bulb or whatever
you know but some people nitpick at what
they like and they don't like ya ya make
a [ __ ] detective Latasha not at-at well
I got attacked online by fur supporters
or by PETA so I think that maybe they
put out a cause like I'll wear it on her
you know I have I love vintage clothes
and if I see something that's warm her
you didn't I read live stream the
skinning of a mink remember that was a
little bit it was to Facebook live we
were there though huh you were there no
no time saying they went on my Instagram
I didn't live tweet and I never never
bought new fur but it says old stuff and
I like how it looks and it's just my
style it's glamorous and warm and
functional so I you know but then they
went on my page and we're like I have a
rabbit so me but what happens is as you
get your name and stuff like you're more
of a target people like nitpick at what
you do you know like anything that's
wrong and often you know and if somebody
jumps on you then you get [ __ ] for
your more I think what all heated does
because it was odd because Comedy
Central retweeted some some picture of
me in a fur and then PETA must have sent
that out to their newsletter
whatever gladden every single one of my
Instagram pictures even if I mean
there's none with fur like so every
single one of them was like you're a
piece of [ __ ] I hope you die like every
single head like 90 comments so I had to
go through and like it was really me hmm
um Katt Williams by the way cells for
Cole to the webpage about a networker he
was for Coach Draganov teens where he
makes three oh yes yeah we had a
designer and this guy tells Birkett
wilfer color white their beige and
they're black and he saw these real
expensive alligator boots too I love the
idea of him like at home just like
knitting a fur jacket ah he goes to bed
and like a group of little yeah you all
look exactly like a comes out and
finishes it I was not working with Mike
Epps in Detroit Detroit and now there
was a guy there with it has an exotic
zoo in Detroit and he went if he rents
out Adam with a birthday party when a
kangaroo show up at her Lock everything
up ostrich from Mongoose anything what
aren't muskrat his pooches obvious who
shows up he went viral because he took a
his kangaroo to the module hop in the
parking lot so this guy goes Mike MCS
that invites them to the common oh I
remember this so there's no kangaroos
and we met everyone was asleep and want
to sleep we were there at the time yeah
we were backstage like as we were
walking out where I what the [ __ ] is a
kangaroo got what which is pretty
getting high back to him and I am with
the kangaroo we saw the kangaroo at whoa
[ __ ] kangaroo so started FINA bananas
took a selfie [ __ ] around now Mike s
take the [ __ ] kangaroo on stage you
were there that night and it was going
yo some star hopping - yeah a nice last
the share of my gebbs he took a swipe at
this stuff anything you ran up says like
but then he was but the [ __ ] kangaroo
was startled on stage scared
right so Matt Peter went down on him to
everybody yeah he joined into money and
head up doors back and before I knew
that he brought the the kangaroo on
stage people were beating me up I am
soaking I thought you were breathing you
[ __ ] fat [ __ ] yeah that was crazy too
but you guys had to take down poster
looks like that way you know on
Instagram people stop [ __ ] with you
you know Peters against pet ownership
really I didn't know that I know they're
very in China between they're against
pet ownership though against Petco are
they all against eating meat oh for sure
there's I don't have had people for
eating me I think they do in a kind of
theoretical way but they target people
because they want public something is
the only way tomorrow PETA they look for
people that are vegan who look like
Natasha you know like petite you know
rule the remodel but someone like me
they'll never put in their posters y'all
[ __ ] big Oh what can I get a [ __ ]
poster nah man we don't need your
campaign yeah [ __ ] right after I hung
out with my Catholic I decided what it
might go years you've been vegan you
don't eat eggs
yeah I'm town done like without honey no
honey
[ __ ] the bees yeah [ __ ] the bees what do
you eat for like because next Kim food
is hard to eat no matter it's all being
so cheese yeah I can eat vegan at any
Mexican place pretty good sometimes you
eat the bean burrito man beans are too
good and you're like Lord you don't want
another night you know whatever go hit a
couple tips sometimes alright [ __ ] it
I know tables my wife tore this place in
Boyle Heights [ __ ] allenbys oh you know
all about oh I'm being oh they're known
for bean and cheese burrito yeah don't
know a larger they don't say anything
about the state Lisa to the next level
you know she's from you know the Midwest
she said can you have deep-fry that for
me and they deep-fry the beanie cheese
one chimichangas wait but hold on how do
you eat allenbys now I don't even know
more we don't go no more ah for the
cheese so what do you eat oh I go to our
organics and ego rock and have jackfruit
burritos and Gringo's they're [ __ ]
good now bro they hook it up you would
you can tell you can't even tell they're
chicken I like that on these placement
like
so the guy who works here so nice and he
lives a two-second commute from his
workplace he lives in the restaurant you
got to go get because la does not have
good burritos I find but that is the
best burrito I see that Natasha said it
blew people our listeners no Boyle
Heights
allenbys I used to go to school with a
kid that his dad used to work there in
the owner and I remember around he was
eating a one of the but one of those uh
lunch burritos uh-huh with a little
plastic and all from the cafeteria like
a material yeah and my friend Coco he
was a funniest guy in school she started
[ __ ] roasting that [ __ ] you
what's up homie then [ __ ] like your dad
huh I'm a peon cheese though man
okay right now I'm Rocco yeah little
tacos tacos corn tortillas and I don't
know you don't like tacos alright let's
go burrito on the what's up full
podcasting you don't like tacos you're
about to walk it out internet that we
know I know he's talking about digital
burritos are amazing you talking about
that place that with a good salsa right
okay a little bit normal in a real bro I
thought that you haven't been there
that's that's good there's a bit of a
kiss on those day - I've never been
there there's a place called my favorite
breeder very controversial it's this
resonant I don't know but gorgeous place
called Gordo's in the bay area that is
uh that's that's the best burrito in the
wood you can't get it here though it's
like it's not flavorful I don't know
what they're doing they're focusing on
tacos burritos are an American invention
right yes yes so burritos don't usually
go like some places like you're right
about allenbys that's a basic
combination burrito that's just good and
then you can choose either its bean and
cheese and you choose red sauce or green
sauce red sauce Chris oh good no she
likes the green I do both because it's
hot I [ __ ] with both you also go to our
badges you could get a you get a hairy
Christmas eating cheese burrito with a
hot dog in it you know about that huh I
rather ain't that or the deep fried one
all right well I'm oh man a hot dog did
I cop it up or the demonstrative
that's what they call natural fudge
right there that right there bro that's
my hood and where were I to go where I
grew up
right there bottom bead it should be a
movie theater I saw Godfather three
little by Barry mama
and what do you what do you think of
have you heard about these anti
gentrification forces in Boyle Heights
I heard of those they're going crazy
right yeah the glow outside Felipa - no
really
don't even mention me on the Boyle - why
should you be I mean I should be
negative on that page meanwhile hi - oh
yeah he stole a pea well I have every
Sun over here where he's doing today -
go far got one of those Mayan
headdresses oh yeah like on the mural I
should be on a [ __ ] bake week a
calendar right now with my feathers with
my wife right there white girl holding
away in the nose why do they hate you I
don't know good yeah they saw this big
they are issues or certain type of
Latino to root for like maybe like a
Latino hipster looking at you know they
root for that like they would like not
get our magical but don't run for our
magical who is not from Boyle Heights al
magical like a prince and boy no no such
a thing he's a Latino they root for okay
wait but what what did what is it about
you that they are hate not because I am
real I am everything that I was you know
well in what way because I'm a talking
like I'm a dog you know I got a high
school and you're an exact product of
it's like I'm the guy who made it with
might without doing it their way without
a college without father guys oh it's
like a it's like a Latino intelligentsia
saying this is the proper way yeah an
activist is that's interesting yeah they
they are protesting the
it's kind of interesting because
obviously the college shop is nothing to
do with me but I'm curious because I
think Jota fication is a really
interesting issue because it by the time
you start fighting it it's already
happened and late you don't go to the
City Council maybe the Planning
Commission meetings where they're going
to you know let you know what's going to
happen flyers after it's you know that's
already a late issue they went to these
white art galleries this is the part I
thought was really interesting which
his white art gallery because the moment
the art galleries come it all shows over
right and they chased them out of a day
where they left they closed up shop
these poor white entrepreneurs as soon
as you see the Chinese grown the white
guy and a baby it's over bro yeah oh
here comes I was there cause of private
school bro we're talking on Sunday
because you did a show in East LA with
Lisa about like all those people that
say all that [ __ ] but and there was
somebody that said something contrary to
their thing that they're uh you are
doing anything to beautify the
neighborhood before yeah bro yo what you
were in or sweeping the streets in the
war you're not no no no forty also in
front of your yard you [ __ ] pick it
up at risk are you gonna get Mexican
white guys having a coffee cocktail that
coffee shop also has a Latino neurone
are the the butterfly one yeah I don't
know which one exactly but I seen it on
that page the yeah cuz Oakland is a cop
I feel that I have a very complicated
relationship with gentrification in
Oakland obviously I'm a white dude so
it's like mainly I'm gonna be like I
just won't comment on this but I also
grew up in a neighborhood in in a city
where people I got robbed so many times
growing up I there was it was on a
certain level like it was [ __ ] up you
know and like now I go back and I'm like
damn this is so different and [ __ ]
like weird that these Jennifer Gatien
forces have come in and displaced people
which is a really sad story and at the
same time it's like I like walking
around and feeling a little safer in my
in my old neighborhood and like I like
that there's some like vibrant
restaurants it's it's a complicated
issue like nobody has opportunities
going to drive in a shitty car when you
have the opportunity by another viewer
one it's going to matter later be more
and also what are people supposed to be
where people who move here supposed to
be buying houses right that brother you
can only buy a house in like a white
area right the idea that you move from
Iowa and you're like what's a white
neighborhood that's why I only want to
live in the white neighborhood yeah like
for Beverly's like oh here here Albert a
mexican-american man they've been living
here for 20 years in his shooting
neighborhood and now somebody offered me
900,000 should I say no you [ __ ]
kidding me
right okay most eight years a more
Riverside or their landlord you know
yeah I bet it ain't his right you know I
couldn't blow I feel both obvious I took
both ways too because it is a sad story
when a historic community can't afford
to stay in the neighborhood that they
created
right but it's also interesting because
you know like Oakland I know what Boyle
Heights of history is it was a Jewish
Enclave because I say exactly everybody
really usually I think then came another
thing Oakland the same thing was like it
was an all-white city and then it became
a majority black City and now it's
becoming this weird gender but the truth
is you can't stop gentrification
there's too many gonna maybe we can help
it so like historical things don't
that's real
don't break don't don't have to be too
you know gotten rid of and you can take
the taxes from a gentrified neighborhood
and put it into housing in the
neighborhood that people so people don't
get pushed out and maybe businesses
could get a tax break who's been there
for a certain amount of time you know so
they don't have to close down or
something right way don't worry wrote
one program could be you get a white
person who just moved about Boyle
Heights and you give them one of those
hot dog burritos and see what they say
you know it's like welcome to the
neighborhood I'm saying I'm not on a
menu because I'm a Jewish area like why
it's right on it's got a weiner burrito
yes yeah I definitely know that too but
every time I go to bought a taco dogs
but that's that loop is on the other
side under dogs it's just a corn
tortilla wrapped around a hot dog but
deep fried all my listen hey with uh
with welcome Paul here food bomb it's
also the way you just tell your friend
you want to talk oh yeah I want a taco
dog taco does I want to know Felipe eats
for breakfast oh I'm sorry I'm just so
enamored by it
Oh malt-o-meal request a multiple bill
to do with syrup Cream of Wheat yeah
clearly weeks hey banana and now denim
and yesterday last night before dinner
we have fall right we have fall with
your favorite vegan spots organics in LA
and we're banging us the best and I like
Tony starts the way here in Burbank is
putting on his darts yes what is that
it's a bar and they have hot dogs well
that sounds pretty good egon hot dog
you know we drove by this new vegan um
ice cream shop right right in the
complex where do mises oh love boobies
there was a there was a line it was like
it was like two blocks on yeah I was
like white people Christmas it was like
it was I guess that's Christmas but
anyway it was the longest line I've ever
seen
perfectly good ice cream oh yeah you
either do these Gavin at Denise yeah
yeah we had the big bag yes I've had the
babes disgusting ha ha ha it is you pull
a [ __ ] out you feel real bad after yeah
I'm real disgusting I'll take a hot dog
burritos are greener Beria jalapeno
poppers are good yeah something nasty
man man when I was in Texas I gotta tell
you guys the collisions natural might be
natural inaudible rhythms for you guys
it's white lady hillbilly lady but short
of a snow cone and guess what flavor she
wanted pickle juice no it's all good I
don't like snow cone so like I think I'd
like a savory one yeah okay martini big
turns
we got a turkey brine and one turkey
Bryan snow cone and I thought you know
what I'll do a doodoo cone as well just
doctoring diarrhea and that and it on
over but it's like having a martini or
something right that's interesting
what's the nastiest kind of food you
like is there some like deep deep [ __ ]
that you guys grew up eating um whoa
well that's a lot of stuff cuz we three
brains no brain tacos and tongue you
know I was looking up cholesterol
because I had high cholesterol a few
years ago and I was looking up the
different cholesterol in the foods and
like bacon will be like 80 and like
steak will be like 90 shrimp of a like a
hundred brains was like 1,200 percent
like a very high-level collaboration
yeah aha it was such a jump it was it
was crazy brain is your brain is pure
cholesterol nice cute cow cheeks oh yeah
cow cheeks all over them we were an um
we were actually enough I just remember
and I can grew when we were announced to
them we were an incident yes I can't
remember and he's like I puked in your
room and asked you ban we would add oh
we did that one show um what's his name
Ramon is not yeah Raymond Raymond
Raymond is it on that was the show where
I got out there and cuz they you do it
in English yeah they don't speak great
English no
because the whole show is Dutch and then
you're part of the English yes and so I
remember I got out there my opener was I
don't think women are funny either and
this woman in the front row this is a
live taping she goes if they don't think
women are funny why she on stage during
my taping like they just don't
understand irony or sarcasm language
obviously but they didn't understand
like they're just translating like like
literal it was not not good for me
did you girl yeah man I got for dog
afterwards though disappeared for a day
a bit much life there was I don't know
if you noticed but you remember that day
the host the whole time we were there
but I was there with somebody it ended
up going home alone you were there
people were looking for Philippe yeah
waiting to ring a bell was dubbed a bit
off what David off with us yeah okay
because I went twice I'm Jasper red
there no Jeff Jeff we were able to go
and he disappeared too I always gone
brought disappeared and I you know what
happened to you know I went obliged to
some house and I was like smoking heroin
yeah we're Wiener in it though right
yeah yeah and then you don't know if
heroin and then just like passed out
circle no no just forgot laughter I
didn't know what time and Worth and by
the time I come back everything what
they were looking for me bro
but you did you say things as in my tape
after that oh yeah I would do at the
tape in my work I've put in my work
further then I get crazy afterwards I
was smoking heroin
oh man remember to drunk Chloe no but I
was getting drunk man I don't remember I
was on too much acid I said oh the give
of the heroin and they gave a little
foil in a straw and a match and then go
for a man you party
so they are really yeah man weak but
I've been over no foil and the lady she
put like a little piece of my heroin on
it and then she laid it and then she
goes now inhale so inhaling with a straw
and she goes okay you got it now all
right you do it so just doing to myself
I threw up right away immediately throw
up yeah
but they another lady she immediately
wanted you to be the only one smoking
heroin
yeah she was sure the lady that brought
me to the
I met her to another guy met so we're
just parting the whole day and all night
and locals are never dirty well [ __ ]
this room really
yeah just bought antiques in Amsterdam a
different experience went to Van Gogh's
houses
what's with Van Gogh's house also nailed
on is it worth it to party like that
hell no what a waste of time yeah too
much time my brother will spend my time
watching that play there being like that
you could do both though a lot of people
smoke heroin and then watch Netflix
he was the heroin I know I I feel like
I'm the type of person like that's where
I would draw the line as when someone
hands me tinfoil like that's just not my
vibe like I'm not going to do that
here's the straw and ten point either
party that's where that's where I'm just
kind of like it's not for me
and also I don't like opiates they took
oxycontin once and it made me like I
couldn't stop vomiting my eyes nor did
it know someone gave me a pill oh that
happened to me once I did I just felt
like it was like half of a pill I don't
know but it was like I was driving home
and I am a ride a horse and I would like
kept moving the fur to like vomit out
the side on the side of the car and it
was awful and then I've taken a vicodin
before and just woke up on the bathroom
floor like I'm not into that vibe of
thing wasn't it man we're very hairy and
then I did I mean I did cocaine once I
mean those are like I've only done all
of those rococo experience I mean it was
very typical like in New York someone
handed me a tray and I just started
laughing and blew it everywhere and I
was with all these Israelis and they got
mad and then I don't know mad money then
I felt bad so I took some oh and then I
was up all night long I remember I read
a no exit and like two other plays by
John Hart and then sarch as I say it's
all true and then I woke and I go didn't
John John Sartre what's his name I think
of John wick jean-claude jean-paul
Sartre John Pelham side jean-paul Sartre
I read these John stars I read these
plays and then I was like I just
couldn't sleep and I woke up the next
morning and I was like oh my god I'm a
dick
cocaine I was like oh so like in my head
about it that I just never did it it got
to her problem is that she because she
went to Catholic school and it was
raised Catholic every time she does a
vice and she likes it she then
immediately has a thought of I shouldn't
have done that but you shouldn't do
cocaine cocaine sure but when you
shouldn't do you should not remove
heroin even when you smoked sausage
smoked pot but when they have with you a
little bit garlic I shouldn't do that
well I mean I don't think you should
smoke weed all the time I would like to
wake up every morning and smoke weed me
too
do you smoke anymore there's kids around
though would you smoke anymore yeah do
you smoke pot yeah is that it just pot
you drink no no just pot that's on the
drug yeah mushrooms the best job
sometimes would you go hooks it up yeah
occasion way do you do mushrooms I tried
them I dunno
you don't seem like a mushroom guy no I
like the last one I had I didn't like it
bad what it does yeah but they're cool I
think in your liking a good little
element good little energy like be like
ecstasy no I never done that's never not
cuz I heard it something it leaves a
hole in your brain or some [ __ ] like
that
any time you're away for three days any
time you hear a rumor like that but a
weird anti-drug man at the other end of
it yeah they believe my life I heard
someone say once and I've always thought
of this avoid white powder and really
and that's like you know even flour
sugar here are people MDMA
but like you know all of its not really
good for powder than the movie powder
let's have it out right now sting really
help people get away from cocaine right
now I never tried no more [ __ ] that I
want to read no [ __ ] bozo
but ayahuasca you done that no will you
that you don't know about that chemical
that's not like burying someone though
yeah what the jungle fish like Peruvian
like you know with like the Peruvian
native and Nate I don't what are they
like peyote or something it's mega
payload oh wow you go to Peru there's a
shaman they give you a tincture you
vomit up your ego
yeah you vomit or you go up you have
these visions and then you come out of
it like you know a different person yeah
you die a lot of time
literally no but you know I'm sorry
typing Union even know that Lehmann
Piper you [ __ ] you know I know just
to get a [ __ ] about Karabakh about out
it was great I would do done it no no I
like your vision of us was great I went
to Peru I took i wass cup
I was just brutally raped for about 17
hours and I came out a different person
the whole time thinking about our
cottage Brooklyn king of the hill with a
little bit of sweat tent and everybody
put into Japanese people hallucinate
there I would do it though I would go to
Peru yeah yeah why not get bit by
mosquitos I want to go all the way over
there do it burning and doing a mellow
really yeah they know they have these
gatherings in Malibu it's a whole ritual
and it's a whole like you have to have
like a shaman
did you can do it without then of a
shaman yeah
what's a shaman what's the point in
doing it without without a series I'm
sorry like really isn't it's gonna be
someone like Martine dog there was a
media prayer we had last week that lead
to that though what is it Ricky Ricky
Ricky Ricky is the guy that you want to
be on you but your breakfast before
that's an Arabian we did type of yoga
yeah thank you know what that what it is
a kind of energy work where they put
their they don't touch you they just put
their hands around you yeah it's crazy
it's been nice exact woman Kabbalah in
Chittoor
but Reiki break have you ever done DMT
you ever smoked DMT no what's that
what DMT is a drug it is the Molly it's
not Molly no DMT is the is the active
psychoactive ingredient in ayahuasca and
it's the concentrated version and you
know when you do mushrooms you do acid
you have a like you're in this room but
the room is moving when you smoked DMT
you're not in this room anymore you're
in a cave somewhere with a you know man
that last like 20 seconds it last five
minutes wrong here right yeah and you
have a full hallucination like you're at
her defense
yeah mouse did it was better who do the
mouse
is a cool friend I've got Martine a
Reiki practitioner you got the mouth no
mouth understand one of them he's one of
advice yeah but he said it was crazy
doggy was like in a whole tunnel to
going dog instead he farted food in the
[ __ ] lasted like 10 minutes thought he
had come in apart and then this other
fools doing bmp-2 because other fools
hooking it up
he's our dude I [ __ ] heard something
on the other side as a capsule dog it
was crazy I don't want to do it cuz I
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] I not come back
yeah you don't want to come in that bar
but you will come back though that's the
thing about easily they call it the
business man's drug because you could do
it on your lunch break
really yeah you're like okay well I'll
be right back you go into the parking
lot smoked DMT meet God have a
crystalline entity touch your third eye
and then you come back to work file some
more papers okay what's the one where
you see elves that's DMT I did that one
no you didn't I love you did not I was
it was in mall I did MDMA though that's
what Molly what are you talking about I
saw elves
I had a hallucination be tutorial but I
don't know what drug it was I think it
was them DMA wait what to tell the story
I just remember closing my eyes and
seeing all these like Keebler elves or
what were you doing talk to me about a
bunch of shorter covering much of Rizzo
Nicky Guerra and sort of comedians at
Broadway if they were in a bad mood that
Williams Broadway they were just Albert
bad man how did you do it I just took a
pill pill with someone and I was at two
bunch palms and then I like lay down and
then I just saw like like all these
Keebler elves they just were like I
don't think I see Mt Harry cookies they
were like they were like in like a very
primitive you know like almost Bobbitt
no like Hobbit before they figured out
how to make the toe of the shoe curler
it was old-school thing they were
outside and it wasn't there wasn't like
that's cool who you with knowledge
mother now I'm to get power you have
Tori together yeah we're going on tour
together yeah awesome yeah we're a
Europe tour huh no we won't do that
though those are those
last year we did Oliver slab oh yeah
last year we went on to our West Coast
edition so this year this summer we're
doing the East Coast in the south so on
July 19th we start in New Orleans and we
go to Atlanta Miami then we go to
Montreal Boston Philadelphia New York
Chicago Milwaukee and Minneapolis oh you
such a good see this is why people
should be sober you have such a good
July and August
yeah July and August we started July 19
July August 6 yes and we also give a
relationship advice yeah we bring our
show we do stand-up and then live
relationship counseling someone has
gotten married from our show we really
bring people together it's almost like
when we do our own sets like motional do
set I'll do a set and then we'll come
out together and you know talking to us
really acts as a catalyst if you think
maybe a relationships in trouble there's
a little thing you'd like to address
come to our show
so just a question I know and make it
make it make a romantic holiday out of
it ok sounds like a yes come to Miami
you know you know we might not be coming
to your city because I don't want to go
to that many cities right right but we
have why don't you come to us it's a fun
show and we help people and we make them
laugh and it is really we don't really
help you it's mostly for comedy sake but
it's fun we do rehab that may bring
couples on stage and we and we [ __ ] with
them and it's real fun we [ __ ] with them
yeah what's the name of the tour so
endless honeymoon tour honeymoon tour
you guys have an LA date no we did LA
already last year maybe we'll do it
again we do it again but no we're we're
all over the country I'm excited about
these big guys going to Yakima
Washington no it's all East Coast all
these clothes my back yeah I'll go to
Miami though that'd be fun Miami well
we're doing that Lynne we're going to
these different cities we go to the most
densely populated people of color
neighborhoods and we bring an all-white
audience in and we show them around the
real estate market in rubber hood and
sort of also get to know the
neighborhood yeah it's really fun like
we're the we are the invading hordes
yeah I used to have a joke about that my
first special i bought a justification
remember that i said i'm a good mic cuz
i remember my name my room was
changing my world living that and I said
don't be doesn't know don't know judging
by my neighborhood because I do the my
own graffiti outside I shop with people
I mug people because I want my
four-bedroom apartment to stay at six
hundred bucks a month uh-huh that's real
I won't live in man and a good spot
everywhere I lived I was like the
youngest guy coming in there were Latino
couples and remember where Lisa was
trying to find a spot we don't have we
don't rent to white people really thank
you I rented us ivan is Gabriel's
assistant is a friend of mine that's
interest another one is that bad they
don't want to rent to her because you're
a divorce it is racist but is it bad I
don't it's interesting because the other
option is rent to whoever and then know
that the people of color are going to
get pushed out thank you so weird like a
good a good tenant who can who has a job
who seems yeah why do you suspect oh no
I'm kidding an artist gentrification is
such a complicated topic because both
sides you get [ __ ] no matter what
happens either you either you act out of
fear and and frightened and bigotry on
the one hand or you allow your community
to get decimated economically and we
neither are good options but some of
them don't know and they they celebrate
like a girl that I grew up with who
still live there they finally built a
Carl's jr. in the neighborhood she was
about to cry she was so happy you're so
[ __ ] happy with that famous star I
don't have to catch two busted no to get
to get a cookie Carl jr. it was in our
neighborhood was in the industrial area
by Sears by the factories that's the
only one that was there another one
actually in the hood two buses to get to
Carl's yeah that she was happy she was
oh my god cause doing all we need is a
target dream
they were happy when a 7-eleven moved in
because you don't know that what
7-eleven attracts homeless people I had
a joke Wednesday when they opened up the
whole foods that are downtown LA they
were interviewing homeless people to see
what's gonna beg in front of it
what kind of what kind of art can you
bring to our hopeful well I miss you one
limb let me see the side in tap-dance
we're so cool give me other Daisy I
wanna pull yeah we'll go to Moshe kasher
kamar Natasha Leggero comm four tickets
to our shows and try to get them in
advance if you are going to come be good
he'll sell out and we're excited we're
going to Boston that'll be a fun show
new oil I love North that's where we got
engaged in the world's we're going back
to celebrate our love get some beignets
it costly as hell yeah
that yeah you can they're vegan yeah the
artist daughter and Rouge on we asked
where Baton Rouge and there's a great
place called the cabeza it's a bit of a
tourist trap but they have a good they
have a vegetarian gumbo it's called the
gumbo shop and if you ever go they got a
nice veggie gumbo it's real good go
ahead and get you some I'm trying to get
a shrimp po-boy that's not vegan but
it's good yes are you vegan you're not
vegan oh you are okay yeah maybe when
you go to New Orleans you cheat you know
show on Comedy Central I have a show on
Comedy Central called problematic we
just wrapped our first season hoping
about our second season but you know who
know you can get it on a night out
season one we always on it under when
they did it though you are one of our
cat shows you know awesome bro cool show
yeah it's a good guys eye and thick
topics yeah we like things like
gentrification you had it you had an
Coulter on and talked about all right we
talked about the all right we talked
about the dark web one episodes all
right one episode was a dark web one
episode was is the internet making a
stupid one episode was was cultural
appropriation one episode was
Islamophobia we we went to sue you went
there we go there we do go there and I
had another one when I was on it was two
to one to liberals against one Democrat
I was like yeah we should work with the
Republicans and get these right into the
world Facebook know right it was
hardcore liberal like I was cool yeah
with left versus left like the left with
guy better than Iran I'm hooligan here
with Hillary Clinton
that's a BOGO right yeah no that's the
other guy yeah rasca you didn't say that
then that would have been cool I
remember
oh the big email business because the
joke was not the joke but the the
premise was to get someone like Felipe
who sort of doesn't really change on
sides doesn't care whatever see what he
thinks of these two who swings Felipe
and it wasn't even dealing with the
Republicans because the Republicans are
outright it was like the truth like the
future of the list anyway it's called
problematic and it's available you could
you could get it on the comic Central
app and then Natasha has her third
season of her show coming out history no
no it's called another period but it was
a serious the season 3 will be
premiering with drunk history on Comedy
Central joke is I've been on mystery and
the director of drunk history is the
same director for our show so there is a
connection here at peace
yeah very quick question do yes sir are
you named after Moshe Dayan no no Mohsen
I am named after me ha ha ha Moshe dr.
Moses Moshe is a very common Jewish name
and so we're both named after Misha you
name it to Depeche Mode I look like I'm
in zero I think it's what you're getting
at but no Moshe Dayan is is the other
faith I'm not not the same famous but
he's the other known Moshe right okay no
yeah I don't know six days water
yeah that's a he is the model they say
for the Raiders guy
oh yeah guy okay I am totally ever that
before as well yeah um you're on a show
that I have to like that matter on the
more let me guess let me guess
truTV no okay another cartoon actually I
makes okay okay
Oh life and times of times yes okay yeah
bad matter so really no less so I feel
like I watched a few and it was it was
really good and I liked what I liked
about it is the very kind of how would
you say it lo fly drawing you know like
very like not even three dimensions kind
of how they do South Park I don't know
what the exact
illustrator term is what kind of a cobra
do di Vulcano
yeah I was chair but it was a funny a
show so suddenly find those cool man do
you know why I got taken up there what
the deal is with it I mean I don't know
I mean I wasn't on it that much I think
I was on a couple times but I know
people love it and I thought it was
really funny too
the one that was talking about here that
Teresa with a little with a little Augie
shirt ha ha honey did here's a new
here's a new show and it's an Amazon now
but the guy who created that Olivia well
the pilot I watched were so full dates
coming up all right man
July 10 p.m. okay Oliver July 1st
that's today Tuesday on Arizona Saturday
at the amphitheater with Paul Rodriguez
Tierra mallow and war whoa two tickets
July 30 to the 50 Corpus Christi Texas
at mesquite Street comedy club July 24
23rd Tampa Florida at the Tampa improv
July 27 through 29 de Moines Iowa
funnybone West against 3206 levelly live
in Oxnard also in August are being
Braille and Milwaukee minute Milwaukee
minute with Milwaukee be Milwaukee
Wisconsin
check out Philippians world's data at
Philippi world - tour take everybody who
showed up to our Fat Boy yard sale
Michael schooled us he told a lot of xxx
was there any bad things that happened
there any anywhere does a lot of [ __ ]
weirdo so there's no meaning that 150
was 5 bucks to bargain for 4 dollars
hey so come up the quarter he gave you
dog for that little ball he thinks of a
random ball off the ground they were
selling he didn't give me a quarter for
a dollar and he gave me a quarter yeah
all right he just wanted to barge it our
neighbor his old lady she was fighting
with a little girl were a toy she said
give it to me wait I want to do this
just to have this experience you should
man a good little man yo it was we don't
I don't want I don't understand it but
it was like hey take our jug and give us
money we don't want to play for a truck
dog big clothes still had a lot of [ __ ]
after oh man you can rent a dumpster for
like $100 for the week and you can just
put all that [ __ ] in a dumpster
or you could not spend 100 and make
almost $50 no we said though is what
else before we left we put everything
out in the yard real neat and at least I
came out the next day and it was all
gone are you serious
they just came on offense they just came
with Bret walked right in walk they took
it off hey you know what like you want
to happen with it we don't fit this
table that folio nine people bleep and
it's funny we end up giving our clothes
to that old lady who's gonna take her
clothes to a third world country
watermelon for the poor kids this is
gonna be the funniest think of what in
that bag there's a water or Wonder Woman
costume red boots
somebody's over there and that's gonna
be that singular matter be your son yeah
fine ms-13 he's like this is how they
dress in Los Angeles were so food take
you very much to our guests Natasha
Leggero and Moshe kasher thank you for
having us
Thank You Man go check out their tour
fool